[Music]
[Applause]
okay I want to thank every show every
show dude remember like Matthew make
that was Rome at TV that was the that
was like a demographic right sure that's
all you would you would I would go to
the West Covina mall well to get [ __ ]
recognized there you go yeah that I
don't know is that near San Clemente no
it's over there by City of Industry okay
yeah yeah and that you would go to the
food court
yeah and that's where would happen
that's what mobbed welcomed a TV bro
yeah yeah you don't mom come on Maddie
vo yeah and then you go to the Beverly
Center nothing no no zero taking another
water sir yeah yeah but and I wanna
sentiment a little bit oh good what do
it I want to uh what is that a thumb
drive it's a very vise quit smoking he's
oh cool
Bobby's got a son that is a thumb drive
a short is actually how you charge it to
owe us me alright yeah but I wanted to
thank you because you were really I'm
being real you're really nice to me
whatever we were buddies I understand
that but you really brought me in and
you were the only one that gave me then
you're your number like I didn't talk to
Mike McDonald for three years you know I
don't think I ever really even talked to
Stephanie Stephanie where we are yeah
she was he high and stuff but I just
just definitely never talked yeah Moe
was nice
I was very nice Alex was very nice when
she was very no because she was leaving
though yeah and I remember when Alex
when I got on the show and she was like
her last week
oh yeah she goes this was the biggest
mistake of your life doing the show oh
really
I go what she goes yeah you [ __ ] up
your lot and I go ok bye
yeah yeah I mean that's what literally
she pulled me aside and said that really
Debra was nice
everyone come on Larry's wasn't that
nice Mike was very combative with me
combative yeah you probably you probably
had a lot of the same bits and sketches
and stuff nobody thought you were biting
a [ __ ] Stephanie is so super sweet I'm
not saying they're not mom doesn't we
Moses world no mo is very nice yeah
Moses but you're the one that would call
me like how are you it's not like that I
would never call you and be like yeah
like you invited me to a party a couple
parties so we were pals I think we were
fast friends and then I betrayed you
how did you betray me when you left and
you called me a bunch of times I never
called you about just because you're you
I I called you for like two or three
years and never heard back three years
more like two years let's say it was
probably two years and then but every
time I called you after a while I
realized you were just would not get
back to me so then I started leaving
messages as frank caliendo's in person
yeah or one time you answered and I was
like yeah that wasn't a Frank Caliendo
impression of personal thing it was just
that's just the way I am and I just feel
and I try to change that about myself
like when we know don't worry about how
about everyone knows you're weird nobody
I thought I think that we're better now
you and I yeah we're good friends now
yeah we're good friends now
yeah but we're both you know that was a
long time ago we're both in our 50s that
TV was like in a it was the 80s yeah
seven when did you join 89 no not now 89
no not 89 91 oh I enjoyed 2000 oh okay
yeah I started I was on the show by 8
1983 they just canceled Friday's yeah
yeah and Fox was brand new brand spankin
new but I married with children and
Tracey Ullman Show well that you've not
where's the Simpsons yes at your first
American TV show that you booked no no I
was on I was on a show before was on a
couple of things before that there were
American shows while I was still living
in Vancouver because in Canada you
booked a like one thing a couple things
right yeah yeah I was on a show in
Canada for a few years yeah you do
American movies well you're you know
working and living in Canada
yeah which was fun but when you got mad
was it was exciting oh yeah yeah yeah it
was yeah because that was when you got
on it was when it was the show was hot
well the first two seasons Bryan Callen
was there and then after that yeah I
joined and then you know Callen was not
mad I didn't know that yeah first two
years yeah yeah he was one of the
original cast members yeah Bryan Callen
was that's right and then you got on I
think the the seasons that went kind of
well were like four five six yeah
seven is when I got on yeah then you
guys had you guys had I don't think you
guys got your due from the the the
populace at large yeah we didn't yeah
the comedy the comedy audience out there
that also didn't know that we existed
continued to not know that you guys
existed yeah I continued to watch the
show and thought you did a lot of very
interesting stuff yeah yeah but um it
was when you were on it it didn't feel
like I honestly did not feel like you
were on a show what do you mean oh yeah
yeah I didn't if it doesn't feel now
when you go and show up and you and you
you do rehearsals and you do all that it
didn't feel like you thought I thought
this is coming at times get oh yeah yeah
I think it was a little more ghetto when
we were doing it when you guys were
there cuz I do remember I remember
coming back to do like you know come
back and do a couple sketches now and
then and one of the times I came back it
was like a year or two later and I
remember the [ __ ] the lights weren't on
like oh yeah yeah the guy who owned and
ran the show yeah oh he's cheap yeah and
he yeah there were no lights on I
remember tripping on a big like spool of
wire cables yeah yeah anybody could
break their leg here and then just over
in the corner of the sketch we were
doing that was lit up because you need
the lights there yes
but if he had perfected some sort of
infrared like a night vision yeah yeah
thing we would have you know but yeah I
remember that I remember being real
bummed I remember going and doing the
show and then I was on a sitcom at the
time and then going back to the sitcom
like later that afternoon like I was at
Mad doing rehearsals of shooting the
thing
and then going over and doing the thing
and then the showrunners were there a
craft service and its network television
show craft service right yeah very nice
spread of food and I remember like
talking to them like they were the like
it was like like MADtv were my one were
my dad and then this show was like my
mom and they got a divorce that
everyone's fed a lot of love and stuff
and I remember being like you guys
really and they looked at me from like I
was from outer space cuz I was like
giving them props for doing things that
are just normal yeah having the lights
on you know just like some eggs and
bacon in the morning and [ __ ] it's like
you guys really they thought I was of
course thought I was [ __ ] my right I
did nothing but [ __ ] with them all the
time and all of a sudden I was serious
you just feel the difference yeah yeah I
think the show progressively got cheaper
and cheaper but you don't know the last
you do it at bad the new MADtv
oh dude when I did the new MADtv oh my
god we were in heaven yeah this is like
you go to the craft service there's a
[ __ ] Ritz cracker
yeah right and a half-eaten like baby
carrot yeah that's it
yeah yeah they were literally the pork
whatever I don't know I don't know where
that where that went wrong well I know
why that went wrong it was on Tuesdays
at 9 o'clock on the seeds from the fact
that you can't do what MADtv used to do
now right comedic ly in this climate
period yeah the social climate not the
how many I don't know there's lots of
climates I don't really use that I don't
try to use that word as a smart guy
often so i really showed how stupid I
was there and say climate and then go
climate but um you can't do that show
now first of all yes if you ever watch
old MADtv Clips you're like what we
really got away with crazy [ __ ] they're
not only you know sidelined by that
arrest like you know they're taken down
by that they're also on the scene oh but
you would nine o'clock no way
there's no way kaltaka people very
hospitable a lot of the old writers came
back hey guys and there's no way to do
it there's no way to do it yeah there
was girls too Bobby
I think great guys and girls
guy I think great guys and girl all
right yeah yeah yeah time to get what
wait whoa
see I don't even know how to yeah gotta
be way in this climate okay yeah yeah if
you're gonna do comedy you have to wake
up you have to wake it but you were
young though you're like 23 you when you
got that show 22 not imagine [ __ ]
being 22 yeah that's a [ __ ]
incredible yeah it was really stupid of
them what do you mean I don't know I
mean literally I would just go like
you're so [ __ ] funny what you thought
talking about well you know I used to do
stuff like this like I was I was
convinced the show would be off the air
yeah like after the first season I was
on it season three so I was like well I
just got to get as much tape as I can
and I gotta get you know and you know
the show wasn't as competitive as say
you know like Sarah alive from what I've
heard yeah yeah but there was still like
get your [ __ ] on right yeah and I
remember I would I would hang out
Wednesdays all the writers would pitch
so Tuesday nights I would be in the
office until all the writers had
something with me and the the one of the
guys who really took me took me in was
Mike short Martin shorts older brother
who wrote on SCTV
and he was a writer on the show and he
used to call me little buddy because he
was like 6 foot 5 really really fat so
it's funny and he said and he goes and
like Tuesday nights after he'd be
finished his assignments of writing all
right little buddy come in here go all
right little buddy one of my pitches and
everyone had to have three pitches
why are you right now he's like I don't
want to pitches and sing around you know
tessie TV these guys want me to pitch
Winston this is a very good impersonate
very good get on and he goes what are my
pictures and I'm like okay so this one
I'm a lady I'm just giving me [ __ ] you
know thing and then I'm a Martian and I
got a big purple and the next day he
would go okay here's another will one
he's a lady and
anyway and then after a couple weeks
they're like are you Mike are you just
letting will right cuz terrible pitches
none of them ever got written up yeah
and you Layton will write you pretty
goes I want to pitch on Wednesday
mornings wanted any with [ __ ] ICTV
cuz he wasn't there when I was out no
Mike left yeah a couple years and I
think he left in season before by the
way just FYI Martin Short I never met
that'll draw and short but Martin Short
yeah probably the nicest people very no
my god good good Canadian stock yeah
just really just personable and like
yeah his stories are [ __ ] amazing
just a nicest guy yeah however that was
great what's great about that show too
is is that you got to meet like all of
dick blue cheese people that he grew up
with so you would you would see Eugene
Levy let me would come back yeah and all
those kind of those pirated the show
yeah those types and you're like holy
[ __ ] yeah I am a part of some sort of
like you know Paul Flaherty directly
already yeah and his brother of course I
think George would hang out his daughter
yeah and do sketches sometimes yeah man
it was like really cool in that way you
know and and kids in the hall writers
yeah Mary Campbell all those yeah but
you know you're really good at that when
you left it just kind of you know I had
a good you know we have Jordan - yeah
you guys talking it was the keegan
really good stock you know yeah what are
you doing gilbert just emailing
[Music]
you
[Music]